so these two come with a hefty price tag
and consumers are always split between
having the best amounts in the market
with the xm5s or having an aesthetically
pleasing pair of cans which are the
airpod nexus but the thing is both of
them sound great so let's just walk
through which one comes on top
[Music]
hi dino and welcome to geek culture we
do a lot of stuff here so the next video
might be different from this one but
today we have the sony xm5 and the
airpod max's in the house and i gotta
say after testing them both out they
both sound good from a consumer's
perspective of course i know the audio
files are sharpening their knives right
now but they both sound good in their
own rights they're both amazing
headphones and the thing is you know if
you want flat clear sounding headphones
you go with the xm5s however if you want
something bright and something looks
great you know you go with that apple
max's and the thing is you can't go
wrong with getting either all but the
thing is there are a lot of key
differences between the new xm5s and
these apple maxes that need to be
discussed so the thing i need to get out
of the way first is that the apple maxis
came out in 2020 and the xm5 came out in
322 so there's a huge studio gap in
between both these headphones and we all
know in tech that that's that's a long
time you can't really say it's a fair
comparison but i will say the airport
maxes still hold their own very well
after all this time so out of the box
the airport max's sound better than the
xm5 is because you know apple users love
the ease of accessibility and apple
caters to that so there's really nothing
much you need to do in order to get
these headphones to sound amazing sound
staging wise it's very wide i could hear
everything going from all the way to the
back to the front of the headphones and
it's pretty damn amazing what apple has
done here it's very bright at least to
my ears you know it sounds good and
while i was listening to frankie goes to
hollywood's welcome to the pleasure dome
i could pick out everything i could hear
the birds literally flying across the
back of my head to the right side and to
the left as well them chilling here and
going there things going through the
water and then when the vocals kick in
you know everything blends in really
nicely and it's
quite the auditory experience and also
the other thing i touch on is how the
clarity and the separation of the
instruments i can literally pick up
everything that's going on especially
when i listen to bands like snarky puppy
or toe i can pick out everything that
happens and say short for khan by saki
papi when it comes to the main band
where there's the bass line on the lead
guitar and hearing all the brass
instruments and everything going on you
know it's you can clearly separate
everything even the keyboards all
however the xm5s you need to go to the
sony app and tweak it a little bit with
the equalizer to get them sounding the
way you want them to because out of the
box you know they are in default mode
you know everything is flat which isn't
a bad thing because you know it's kind
of similar to how modern headphones work
in music production which is something i
prefer because i like to pick up more
things especially like since i deal with
music stuff on the side but yes having
that extra option to change up your
equalizer for the headphones is a big
plus because the thing is like if i want
to change stuff with my apple max's i
can't do it in the way that sony does
with its app so if i'm listening to
spotify anything i literally display the
equalizer in the spotify app i know that
there are more other settings for the
maxes via the airpod segment in
accessibility but they're still not as
comprehensive as those found in the sony
app and the thing about these headphones
is that you know the airpod maxes are
for people who love easier accessibility
and they look great and so are the xm5s
and these are for people who love their
customization you know so these two cams
they're right on their own ends but the
thing that brings them both together is
that they're both great sounding
headphones here at geek culture we love
our keyboards especially with the all
new logitech mx keys mini an elegant and
functional keyboard its ultra responsive
rounded keycaps are super stable and
quiet for more productivity there are
buttons to enable dictation microphone
audio control and emojis the backlit
keys illuminate when you get close and
matches the lighting of the environment
you're in it lasts up to 10 days on a
full charge or 5 months with the
backlights turned off to find out more
about the logitech mx keys mini and
their latest range of products head over
to logitech.com okay so between two
headphones right uh a and c wise
sony wins ah like
sony sony will and did i say so myself
die on this hill when we say that they
really do have the best anc in the
market with two q and one chips right
compared to the one q and one chip that
was in the xm4 this is a keys by the way
this thing when it came out this is
really great people love this
even with xm3s what am i going to do
thanks even with the xm3s
even with the xm3s when these came out
these are great it's sony if you want
noise cancellation honestly look no
further than the sony's because the
thing is they really are the best in the
market for years on end now but that's
not to say that bose and apple have
terrible anc they actually have amazing
anc and if anything they come pretty
close to the xm5 it's just that these
guys are like a smidgen better than than
them so the thing is ambient mode on the
apple max or even like the airport pros
or so they work pretty damn well
compared to like the sony stuff even
compared to the earphones because like
it's just the feeling you get when you
hear the wall quieten out when you
switch from ambient to anc mode on the
apple max is like it's a nice little
swell that goes from 100 to zero and
it's really satisfying to hear because
when you put the sony's on you know you
can hear the anc working pretty damn
well because it cancels out the higher
and lower frequencies pretty fast
compared to the apple max's but that's
the other thing we need to get into
which is the cabin pressure when it
comes to using these headphones so the
thing is with the sony is that you
automatically optimize your anc no
matter where you go and the thing is in
previous iterations with the xm3s and
xm4s you would have to do it manually
before you enter new era or even when
you're in that new area as well but with
the xm5 it's a lot better now because
everything's automatic you don't need to
constantly change up your anc settings
wherever you go however with the apple
max's um
i mean okay
the anc is great on these okay the thing
that
i don't like about these is that um you
know given that it's a product that came
out two years ago mind you of course
is that you know the the cabbage
pressure when it comes to cupping them
in your ears it gets a bit much
sometimes you can feel it getting
squashed or anything and sometimes it
just gets really uncomfortable and it
just speeds up the whole headphone
fatigue that you have and we haven't got
the clamping force yet and for me that
was one of the main factors that kind of
got to me when it came with the airport
max's so the xm5 still win in this
regard so coming into like how
comfortable they are first off um the
weight on the xm5 is coming at 250 grams
and the weight on the airport max has
come at 386 grams and these things are
heavy you don't need long for the kind
of hippo fatigue to set in because like
you know it's all made of metal the
headband is great and all you know it's
really comfortable on the top but when
it comes to the clamping force and
everything it's it does get very heady
after
a while so everything else aside both
companies thought that their microphones
on both headphones offer great clarity
when it comes to speaking into them for
calls and all so we're going to go into
the street and just see how well these
two hold up so this is how it sounds
like with the sony x5 microphones my
friends we are here are having
meaningless conversations behind me
there's like traffic in the front
and you know this is how it sounds like
still not sure how clear it is so just
move on to the airports all right so
this is how the microphones on the apple
meant to sound like traffic right over
there we got people friends over
here abby
and yeah i have no idea how it turned
out but we'll see how it goes when we
get back to the studio it's safe to say
the xm5 and it's eight microphones have
come on top they're not super clear but
they definitely get the job done but
remember the two-year disparity between
the two sets of cats so go into the
design and accessories of both
headphones let's start with the sony's
first because
why do you all want to try to fix
something that wasn't broken in the
first place i mean when it came to the
xm3s you know these are great and the
xm4s these are great these were
award-winning formulas and i still don't
understand why you only need to break
away from that the xm5s and its carrying
case looks very similar to a certain
bose 700 for some reason
and you know the whole point of having
sony's in the first place back then or
even like now as well it's that you know
people wanted great sounding headphones
with amazing anc but were also compact
because of things you could fold them in
like this you can just throw them in and
nothing just forget about them because
that's how it works and the things a lot
of people use them for traveling when
you go on planes and stuff and things
you guys know that but now with this
thing it's it's even clunkier than
everything it's not really a deal
breaker for me because the thing is like
i don't mind i always carry like a huge
bag whenever i go but for people out
there when there's a lot of them by the
way would prefer the compact design of
the xm3s and xm4s and that was one of
the main selling points for the threes
and fours in the first place so um i i
don't get it like i said just now you
know if it ain't broke why fix it like i
get it you'll want to try something new
but at the same time just don't and now
shifting over to the apple max's
i don't know what this thing is
every time i put them up in my bag right
i'm so afraid that some way somehow like
i'll snap off the headband for some
reason and like i know that you know
it's important to
protect the main cans but at the same
time also like i would love some
coverage on the headband as well and
like not to say that they're not sturdy
at all these things are hella sturdy but
the thing is that it's always that what
if you know and just having
a pouch like this if i can even call it
a pouch you know it's
kind of raises my anxiety a little bit
so maybe with the second iteration of
the apple max's apple maybe have a whole
case instead of doing this thing because
this thing does scare me quite a bit the
sony's it's it's very nice on the inside
and it comes with a nice little magnetic
compartment here opens up like that you
have a usbc cable here which charges up
the headphones and also you have a 3.5
millimeter auxiliary cable and these are
the ones that come together with it
they're not extremely long but the thing
is obviously if you want to use
aftermarket wires you can do that with
xm5s so the only thing that comes with
the airpod maxes are its carrying case
and a lightning to usb c cable and yeah
there's nothing much going on here if
you want to get the lightning
to the 3.5 millimeter jack you also have
to get that separately apple doesn't
really give you a lot of stuff when it
comes to being that much of a price
because honestly that price is just
meant for the headphones itself and
never gets accessories badly sony gives
you these options included with
headphones which is nice but the only
thing that it's missing is the airplane
headphone adapter which comes with the
xm4s and xm3s and that is in here now so
before i end this off you know i have to
say again that this is coming from a
consumer's perspective so i'm looking at
everything i'm looking at the aesthetics
i'm looking at what accessories come
with it and how they feel over time
because you know people just buy these
headphones just to feel comfortable to
really just quieten the world around
them and just get done the xm5 is coming
at 399 usd and the apple max's come in
at
usd and that's a significant difference
right there in price point so if you're
looking for something that's more bang
for your buck especially if you're an
android user or an apple user you know
the x5s are right there for you guys
yeah it's a well-rounded package with a
ton of accessories a ton of options for
you guys to consider
and you know it'll take you a while to
get used to it especially when it comes
to tweaking say the equalizer on the
headphones but once you get there you're
there so with that leave your thoughts
down in the comment section down below
you know we have two cams here we have
sony and apple and the thing is you guys
are quite fierce when it comes to your
audio stuff just let me know what you
think and i'll try to get to them as
well so don't forget to follow us on all
of our socials like this video and
subscribe to us it helps us out a lot
and this is inio signing off and
yeah
[Music]
you